grégoire frati bonsoir merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur arte
france l'état coupable de carence
fautive et d'action défaillante dans
quel état d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
apprécié le jugement verre à moitié vide
parce que paris ne restent pas ne
respecte pas ses engagements climatiques
ou bien un verre à moitié plein parce
que la responsabilité de l'état est
reconnu en fait c'est pas vraiment
d'étonnement on le savait déjà que la
république française n'arrivait pas à
tenir ses engagements n'arrivait pas
être suffisamment en rambis yeuse la
saga ses actes et ses actes et dans le
sens où ce n'est plus une lubie de
quelques militants qui travaillent dans
leur coin c'est quelque chose que dit la
justice donc maintenant que cette phase
dynaction est acté ben voilà il faut
passer à l'action faut passer aux
réponses qu'on peut apporter et c'est je
crois tout l'enjeu de la convention
citoyenne son climat qu'a posé un nombre
très fort de mesures qui peuvent
répondre justement à cette volonté de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre mais
maintenant il faut garder quoi il faut
arrêter d'attendre le gouvernement prend
acte de cette décision qui va faire
l'exécutif selon vous d'après la
ministre de la transition écologique par
barbara pompili je cite l'exécutif reste
pleinement engagé pour le défi
climatique
alors oui le gouvernement reste engagé
des doigts climat est censé passer au
conseil des ministres la semaine
prochaine en revanche on peut constater
que malgré tout cette loi climat est
quand même en dessous des ambitions de
la convention citoyenne
beaucoup de mesures sont rabotés des
dates on passe de 2025 à 2030
est-ce qu'on arrivera à réduire d'au
moins 40% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre comme la france est engagée à
travers des accords de paris c'est
compliqué je pense que ça va être
compliqué va falloir que parlementaires
qui vont passer derrière soit plus
ambitieux que le gouvernement sinon on
n'arrivera jamais à tenir les objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés collectivement donc
oui le gouvernement espère beaucoup de
cette loi climat nous aussi on espère
beaucoup de cette loi le gouvernement a
posé une brique
il faut que les parlementaires
maintenant la consolide parce que c'est
un enjeu collectif qui va vouloir du
affolant atteindre un enjeu collectif
qui a recueilli plus de deux millions de
signatures il ya une pétition la plus
suivie de toute l'histoire en france les
juges donnent deux mois si je ne m'abuse
à l'état avant des mesures plus
contraignantes simple mise en garde ont
réelle menace que risque concrètement
l'état l'état aujourd'hui est
difficilement contre un et c'est
d'ailleurs un peu dans cette idée qu à
la convention citoyenne on a proposé de
rajouter dans l'article 1 de la
constitution française que la république
doivent garantir la préservation de la
biodiversité la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'état est difficilement
contraint donc justement il faut faire
bouger il faut faire bouger les choses
vont faire bouger nos lois faut faire
bouger notre constitution même pour
aller vers quelque chose qui révèrent
plus de contraintes
parce qu'en fait on ne peut plus
simplement faire de l'incantation
maintenant il faut y aller il faut
pouvoir se se bouger un petit peu donc
je suis pas sûr que l'état puisse être
condamné à grand chose on a bien vu là
c'est un euro symbolique
la juridiction se laisse deux mois pour
pouvoir essayer de contraindre moi je
pense que la meilleure des contraintes
c'est celle seyssel ben voilà des
citoyens qui vont qui vont élire à
chaque à chaque élection je pense qu'il
faut que ses citoyens soient écoutés il
y avait comme vous l'avez dit plus de
deux millions de personnes qui ont signé
la pétition plus de 500 milles pour la
pétition pour la convention sijmens plan
climat les citoyens sont prêts ils
doivent plus être un prétexte pour ne
pas bouger maintenant la république et
l'état doivent s'engager fortement
vous avez évoqué en ce fameux euro
symbolique
ça paraît dérisoire pourtant le pour le
collectif la sphère du siècle il s'agit
je cite d'une première victoire
historique pour le climat est une
avancée majeure pour le droit français
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
paradoxe non je les comprends c'est
quelque chose d'historique de dire que
l'état est officiellement condamné en
fait cet euro symbolique comme le nom
l'indiqué il est symbolique et le
symbole est important dans notre société
parce que ça y'est l'état n'est plus les
plus impunis n'est plus en dehors de
toute réalité et doit et et doit pouvoir
écouter les engagements qu'il prend donc
effectivement c'est une victoire mais il
faut regarder derrière
il faut pas qu'on se regarde le nombril
en se disant chouette on a gagné
maintenant
la véritable question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant que l'état est condamné
est-ce qu'on fait tout pour que les
tabacs puisse s'engager plus fort et
c'est ce que disait madame duflot à la
sortie du tribunal elle disait ben voilà
il ya des thématiques sur lesquelles il
faut bouger
qu'est ce que c'est d'être
recontextualiser à l'ancien ministre de
l'écologie qui est maintenant la
patronne de l'om j'ai oxfam france est
exactement et est justement qui porte
aussi les idées que basso arrêté
d'écologie de l'incantation il faut il
faut arriver à l'écologie de l'action et
encore une fois je le répète mais les
mesures la convention citoyenne sont sur
la table
elles sont ce sont des mesures citoyenne
qui sont a priori dans l'ordre de
l'acceptable maintenant il faut que les
politiques s'en empare il faut que les
politiques
iai et il faut pas qu'il y ait demain
vous considériez aujourd'hui parce que
l'urgence elle n'attend pas film symbole
place à l'action selon c'est selon vos
mots donc grégoire frati merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le co fondateur de
l'association les 150 vous est également
membre de la convention citoyenne et
auteur du livre moi citoyen aux éditions
first à paraître demain